manu dibango qu'est ce que ça fait se
sentait d'avoir un orchestre symphonique
derrière soi et est ce qu'ils seront
aussi nombreux vendredi prochain ouais
mais c'est le rêve de tout musicien fait
un moment donné vous êtes
instrumentistes vous pouvez jouer tout
seul fin juin 12 radios trio quartet ou
ce que vous voulez mais c'est tellement
jouissif c'est un énorme bateau qu'il
faut amener au port quoi alors
évidemment il ya des vagues à tous il ya
toute une vie à l'intérieur d'un morceau
du début à la fin et c'est un voyage
c'est pour ça j'appelle ça d'ailleurs
safari ça parce que c'est un voyage
cette fois ci c'est symphonique donc pas
d'allusion à le loup fait de tuer des
animaux eux
non non non non on a changé c'est safari
autrefois très têtu et les animaux
maintenant c'est les prendre en photo
maintenant on les tue pas de façon tu
pas les notant les jeunes alors vous
allez fêter vos 60 ans de carrière ou
cétacés quoi il ya 60 ans 59 j'ai
cherché j'ai rien trouvé souvent les 60
ans de carrière 50 on casse les
inventions de maisons de disques non non
c'est vrai mais c'est plusieurs vies à
la fois vrai ce que forcément une
carrière il ya des gens qui ont des
plans de carrière nous à notre époque on
n'avait pas ça c'est à dire je suis la
carrière c'est pas la carrière et qui
vous suit
c'est vous qui suivez la tarière ça
devient où ça ne devient pas une
carrière
9 il s'est passé un truc spécial pour
qu'aujourd'hui vous preniez comme point
de départ
ben ça décale j'ai commencé c'est à la
rigolade
bon ben c'est dégueulasse qui donne 60
ans
[Rires]
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
m
vous
[Musique]
non
les